نبقى في اسيا وفي ظل تقارير متزايده عن
نقص خطير في الغذاء بكوريا الشماليه اثار
اجتماع اللجنه المركزيه لحزب الزعيم كيم
جونغ اون تساؤلات عن حجم الازمه فبالعاده
تعقد مثل هذه الاجتماعات مره او مرتين في
السنه لكن الاجتماع الماضي لم يمضي عليه
شهران وركز هو الاخر على القضايا الزراعيه
وزاره التوحيد في كوريا الجنوبيه اوردت
تقارير عن وفيات بسبب المجاعه في جارتها
المعزوله مرجحه طلب فيانجلي مساعده من
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي على خلفيه النقص
الكبير بالغذاء وتواجه كوريا الشماليه
المسلحه نوويا صعوبات منذ فتره طويله في
توفير المواد الغذائيه اثر العقوبات التي
زادتها حده جائحه كورونا واغلاق الحدود
علما ان كوريا الشماليه تعرضت لعده مجاعات
ادت احداها في التسعينيات لمقتل مئات
الالاف
[موسيقى]